for this kiev neighborhood another early
morning awakening from the war
an incoming missile was intercepted with
falling debris killing a resident below
people in cities on the front line like
here in kharkiv continue to bear the
brunt
parents of children at this shattered
school have come together to try and
restore classrooms
he came to help we heard that such a
catastrophe happened and i don't know
how to describe it it's inhuman
there's more fierce fighting on the
streets of the southern port of mariupol
with the destruction of a theater where
ukrainians say more than a thousand
civilians were sheltering
the russians denied targeting the
building
the only way to describe what has
happened today is genocide
genocide of our nation's too
hundreds more people have finally
managed to escape the siege of mariupol
such as lydia who spent two weeks in her
basement without heat or running water
the whole place is destroyed she says
we still had corpses there they didn't
take the bodies away for seven days and
it started to stink already
it was scary very scary
and at the main church for the military
in the western city of lev a funeral for
another soldier killed in conflict
while this war continues to arouse
condemnation of the russian invasion on
the world stage here in ukraine each
death locally seems only to strengthen
the resolve to join the fight
outside lev more training for volunteers
this soldier calls himself cream meaning
crimea
he says he left his home on the
peninsula when it was seized by russian
forces in 2014 and is vowing not to be
moved on again
i'm more interested in a democracy than
in a totalitarian state
these volunteers will soon join others
like former international tennis player
sergey stakovsky who says he had no
choice but to put on a uniform and pick
up a gun
even if i will
be capable of shooting killing someone
is marking you on your life
so i don't believe that any of the
ukrainians are willingly doing it but we
don't have any choice
with both sides seemingly unable to find
a way out as the war goes into its
fourth week casualties are mounting all
around
rob mcbride al jazeera live
british military intelligence says
russia's invasion of ukraine has in fact
stalled across the country a resistance
faced by invading forces has been
staunch and well coordinated according
to the intelligence report
uh here's nadim baba in london nadeem
take us through more of this report
well kamal this is just the latest
intelligence update from the ministry of
defense here in britain
and apart from the points you've just
raised it says that russian forces have
made minimal progress on land sea or air
in recent days and they continue to
suffer heavy losses now just on
wednesday night there was a previous
intelligence update which said as a
result of russian forces basically
failing to achieve their aims at the
start of the invasion on the 24th of
february it is likely russia is
resorting to the use of older less
precise weapons which are less
militarily effective and more likely to
result in civilian casualties well
goodness knows as we've just been seeing
uh in rob's report this civilian
casualties are mounting up and causing
uh huge grief across the country
not just the siege of mariopol but in
terms of heavy shelling of many cities
including kharkiv even though those
urban centers remain under the control
of the ukrainian government the death
tolls are extremely alarming and the
capital kiev of course while it hasn't
been hit in the center um and um the
resistance the ukrainian forces are
trying to keep the russians out of
artillery range of the center certainly
satellite towns or suburbs of kiev have
experienced targeting of civilian
civilian
residential areas so it's clearly not
the case that the russians uh being
thwarted means that the war has been
ground to a halt that things have swung
in the favor of ukraine and certainly
their president continues to argue that
they need more equipment and a no-fly
zone of course which doesn't seem to be
a likely prospect in the near future but
on wednesday britain's defense minister
ben wallace did say that britain as well
as supplying anti-tank weaponry which we
knew about up to now
is now supplying ukraine with um
star streak
anti-aircraft missiles and analysts are
saying that this could be an important
move in the absence of actually uh
foreign powers flying above ukraine's uh
uh airspace um the fact the the fact
that uh the west will be bolstering
ukraine's ability to shoot down aircraft
might actually be significant
thank you nadeem baba for that update in
london